I'm a glass case of emotion okay hi guys
I'm Lucy Hale here at BuzzFeed and I am
here to talk about my first time first
person you thought might have been a on
pol honestly I thought it was aria I
thought for the whole eight seasons that
they were eventually gonna make Aria a
there were so many things that like led
up to it she was always missing in
action and I was wrong I wanted Aria to
be a I think we all wanted to be the bad
guy first time you were turned down for
a role you really wanted where do I
begin I auditioned for High School
Musical 4 Vanessa Hudgens part Hannah
Montana years before Miley got cast was
when I was still living in Tennessee I
auditioned for I was like 15 hairspray
Twilight I auditioned for Ashley greens
part the list goes on and on
me and Ashley Benson used to audition
against each other before pretty little
liars all the time first kiss I knew
this one was coming my first kiss was
with a guy named David Mitchell he lived
down the street from me I had a crush on
him forever and we made out at church no
life what's up David first onscreen kiss
was a Leighton Meester in a pilot that
never got picked up I was 15 I got to
kiss Leighton it's pretty cool first
show you ever binge I think it was
friends I want to say I watched friends
from top to bottom a couple of times now
first show you'd rewatch yourself in if
you had to write now out of How I Met
Your Mother American Juniors are
privileged well how I Met Your Mother
was only two episodes so that would be a
boring binge American Juniors would be
hysterical
um I think privileged it was a show
short-lived show on the CW about two
spoiled twins and their nanny but I'm
still really close with them and it was
a really good show I think it was just a
little before its time it didn't really
catch on okay
first red carpet experience
was for the B movie if you remember the
B movie I felt so cool that I got
invited I'd done nothing at the time but
I got invited to the B movie premiere I
want to say I was probably 16 I did my
own hair and makeup remember we used to
wear like tunics over jeans
that's Ilya sided it was like a black
tunic over some wide leg jeans very chic
was all about the fashion back then and
that was really bad really bad but fun
experience first celebrity crush I have
a few there's Jonathan Taylor Thomas
Zack Hansen and Devin saw those were
like the j14 like Tiger Beat days first
time you ever had coffee I want to say
was at my grandmother's she was the one
in the family who left me and my sister
get away with everything let us wear
makeup first let us watch r-rated movies
first well she let me and my sister
watched the original Exorcist at a
abnormally a young age like we were like
seven years old and I know kids should
be watching that but but I did but I
think that's what sparked my love of
horror films because she let me watch
all of them really young first big
purchase as a celebrity I want to say it
was my first car I got a Prius
a Toyota Prius I loved that car first
makeup splash fashion moment you really
regretted the pencil-thin surprised
eyebrow look and luckily they've grown
in healthy mom why to let me through
that
yikes first time you saw yourself in a
mag magazine I want to say maybe it was
one of those Us Weekly the stars they're
just like us which is ridiculous because
yes we are it was in one of the the like
gossipy magazines and I was like I've
made it now I tried to avoid being the
first apartment it was apartment across
from the Grove in LA and I lived with
Ashley new bro who played my sister on
privileged I just bought my Prius so a
lot of my first happened around that
time lots of bad decisions made in that
apartment but it was good good times
like healthy bad decision it's not like
anything beard first time you sing in
public
eight years old I sang tomorrow from
Annie was mortified
so nervous there's like a little singing
competition in Tennessee
I won some of the trophies somewhere
first memory you have from working on
PLL we were shooting the pilot it was in
Vancouver and it was the dead of winter
and we had like very minimal clothing on
our mouths were numb and when we were
just trying to like heat up our mouths
so we could actually say the words I
think it was the scene where the bodies
being pulled out at the end like the
very last scene of the pilot I don't for
some reason that is my only memory of
that first PLL co-star you'd call to
hang with right now Oh probably Jenelle
I love Janel Parrish but I love them all
they're all good news first
cellular-phone of the nokia the one
where you could play snake and you could
change out the faceplates
it was a hand-me-down from my sister it
didn't even work and I just carry it
around because I thought it was super
cool first time someone came up to you
in public and did the PLL whisper I'll
just tell the story about how that came
about and it was the first time anyone
did it to me we were at a photo shoot
12-hour day we were exhausted and the
photographer was like Lucy shush the
camera and it was the last frame it was
literally the last photo so I guess that
counts as an answer to the question and
they ended up using it for the poster
which is what everyone knows first time
you knew you were famous it was when I
was living across from the growth so I
would walk across scene I'm
incorporating all the First's into this
so I would walk across to the Grove and
there were posters everywhere and that
was like a really surreal uncomfortable
moment but pretty cool okay last one
first a I am for AOL screen names I want
to say it was kick it kicking it with a
cake ai ckin it with loose luc and then
I think was my birthday kicking it with
loose 1989 I still have it okay survived
talking about my first times with
BuzzFeed another first for me is that I
have partnered up with honey nut
cheerios for the good rewards program
and I'm trying to win $100,000 for the
ASPCA what you can do is you can buy a
box of honey
curios and go to be EE good rewards comm
scan your buzz coin and choose a team
preferably mine and help me win money
for the sweet little animals
[Music]